c'est l'argent qui est le coeur de
colère l'argent des autres celui qu'on a
par l'argent des riches leurs salaires
leurs maisons leurs voitures leurs
vacances voilà ce qui est aujourd'hui
insupportable ce qui gagne 1200 1300
milles 800 euros pourquoi eux et pas moi
qu'ai je fait au bon dieu pour traverser
la vie en classe éco quand d'autres
voyagent en première alors vous allez
annoncer demain matin une mesure inédite
vous en parler pour la première fois il
s'agit d'un bouclier anti inflammation
une mesure de protection à sion
inflation inflation j'ai dit quoi
inflammation inflammation ouais bah non
l'inflation reste un peu pareil vous
arrivez vous mettez votre paquet de
pièces dans la borne ça fait un bruit de
machine à sous à celle un peu le jackpot
et savent où sort un bon d'achat et avec
ce bon d'achat et bien vous allez au
supermarché où l'hypermarché et vous
achetez quelque chose alors c'est le
journal le progrès qui a fait récemment
un article là dessus et dans ce papier
on apprend par exemple qu'il ya une dame
qui est venu et qui comme ça a pu avoir
un bon d'achat de 100 20 euros
il s'agit d'une jolie somme un signe
francs et il va
le flux de la vieille école il est très
très vieille école c'est à dire que dans
son décor ça fait combien de temps qu'on
est pas simple au
courant un jour peut-être que l'humain
que je défends tellement sera au sommet
de nos valeurs puisque le monsieur un
mais bien présente tout ça et avec un
représentant de l'être humain alors oui
c'est le champion des humains voilà
voilà et ensemble on t'aime mais on va
pas par contre on va pas bouffer du tofu
ça dégonfle peu mais on va continuer à
bouffer de la viande à boire des coups
tiens bon joueur on soir monsieur gaba
ça va
c'est bien ici aux lois de boire pas le
droit de fumer
est ici pas de passe droit la direction
de l'hôtel est formel c'est pas
tellement la direction de l'hôtel à mon
avis c'est le csa combat je sais pas qui
c'est mais ça mon père il ya deux paires
sayad deux personnages dans l'histoire
qui me fascine c'est jésus-christ qui
était arrivé en disant aimez vous les
uns les autres j'ai quand même un truc
énorme parce qu'avant je t'ai les bébés
dans les poubelles un coin donc il dit
aimez vous les uns les autres et le
deuxième c'est john lennon qui a dit
avant de faire la révolution dans la rue
font la paire dans sa tête ça a l'air de
rien mais si on faisait ça elle réussir
est peut-être la révolution je suis
vachement heureux d'accueillir shirley
dino
mais oui charles et dino du plus grand
cabaret du monde charlie et dino de
patrick sébastien sur scène avec
françois ruffin c'est la première fois
qu'on anime un meeting politique
première fois de ma vie à ce qu'on
espère qu'un jour france passera
président voilà et on sera ministre de
la culture
on raconte que le président mitterrand
débarquer chez au parfois à l'improviste
toujours incognito caché sous une
casquette sans chauffeur sans gardes du
corps même s'il avait marché depuis la
rue lepic
on a dit beaucoup les choses d'ailleurs
pour éviter les risques des services
secrets avaient fait éclairer la rue
d'argent de la nuit comme en plein jour
chargeurs le sujet si vous voulez y à
t'il l'entreprise récupère de l'huile
dans 90 mille établissements en europe
et transforme 250 mille litres par jour
[Musique]
elle est toute neuve cette usine ouais
elle a tout neuf on va construire la
plus grande usine en europe pour le
traitement des huiles de friture usagées
des championnats du monde d'avions en
papier on peut pas se quitter sur une
image on doit avoir une image du lancé
voilà des lancers l'avion
de lancer d'avions rend pas très bien
deux catégories le lancer en longueur et
le vol le temps de vol en l'air et les
avions sont fabriqués rompu et non à 400
grammes c'est très précis comme règle et
moi tu meurs nuit et moi qui m'ennuie le
dimanche
vous vous y participez pas du tout à ces
vols d'huiles usagées nous on va
certainement jamais participé à ça on a
une traçabilité à 100% de notre tous nos
véhicules parce qu'on a eu de nombreux
témoignages qui disent que votre
entreprise aussi récupérer
frauduleusement certains bidon ou
essayent de récupérer frauduleusement
certains bidon dans des restaurants avec
lesquels vous n'avez pas de contrat
on peut couper